Let's consider our
one-dimensional collision
again, object 1 moving
with velocity V1 initial,
and object 2 moving
with V2 initial.
Let's call this or
i hat direction.
And this is our initial state.
And our final state after the
collision, we have object 1.
We'll say it's moving this,
V1 final, and object 2 moving
that way, V2 final.
Now recall our principle
of impulse and momentum.
We said that if there
is an external force
during the time of a collision
delta t, then physically that
will cause the momentum
of the system final
minus the momentum of
the system initial.
Now when we do this analysis,
this side was a description
and this side is physics.
Now for our
one-dimensional collision,
we need to look
at this collision
and ask ourselves are
there any external forces
acting on the system, which
is consisting of particle 1
and particle 2?
So what we're going
to identify here
is that the surface
is frictionless.
And we'll ignore
all air resistance.
And so by our assumptions that
there are no f external is 0.
And therefore, the momentum of
the system remains constant.
So here our statement is-- many
people call this conservation
of momentum, but we're
saying in this example based
on our assumptions that
the momentum of the system
is constant.
Now how do we actually
write that down?
Well, let's now write it
first as vector expressions.
So we have the initial momentum,
V1 of the system, m1 m2 V2
initial is equal to the
final momentum of the system,
V1 final plus m2 V2 final.
Now, how do we represent
these equations?
Well, you could treat them
as vectors if you wanted.
But what we're going to do is
express them as components.
So if we wrote
this as components,
we would have m1 Vx initial i
hat plus m2 V2 x initial i hat
equals m1 V1 s final i hat
plus m2 V2 x final i hat.
So that's the vector
expression expressed
in terms of components.
The advantage of this
is that we really
don't know the signs of
these two final components.
That's our target quantities.
But we could just
write this equation--
instead of writing it
as a vector equation,
let's just now write this
as a component equation.
And when we write this equation
in terms of components,
we have m1 V1 x initial plus
m2 V2 x initial equals m1 V1 x
final plus m2 V2 x final.
And this equation
here is the equation
that we use to
express the constancy
of the momentum of the system.
We'll call this equation 1.
Now our next approach
is to ask are there
any other quantities in the
system which are constant?